hey hello everybody and welcome to a
brand new video today I'm going to be
exploring Dylan or looking for the best
shops to buy items from the benefit of
NPC shops is that oftentimes it does not
require a lot of money to start making
money back from them on top of that
they're oftentimes is not requirements
however there are some exceptions to
that occasionally there will be a quest
requirement and very rarely a skill
requirement to reach the place however
most of them are pretty much requirement
free and oftentimes you won't need a lot
of money to start doing them so we're
gonna start with ten mil now we're gonna
go ahead and explore a bunch of
different shops now these are not going
to be in a particular order however I
will obviously give my opinion on which
ones I think are best alright let's get
started okay so we're the first location
and that is zaps staff shop now this is
a very common spot when people think
about buying items from shops the reason
is is because almost everyone knows
about it the main benefit to this place
is it's very easy to get to it's
literally right in the middle of Rock
and he has a bunch of different items
but what you're looking for is battle
stabs we got one here all right so it's
eight six seven seven on a GE but if we
look at the price here it's 7700 so
you're pretty much consistently getting
a 1k profit for every battle stuff you
buy the main problem here is that of
course there's a ton of bots as well as
legitimate players buying them up here
now one thing you have to keep in mind
is that you will be needing to have
world's very consistently here and if
you are not giving the client enough
time to reset you will get booted out
for too many logins now the best way to
avoid this is to just do it eight a pace
that the client can catch up with
however if you want to speed through
seven or eight world's hops and then
wait for a minute that also can work too
however it's better to just find a
rhythm that works better
okay so we've been hopping the worlds
for quite a while so you're looking at
1k profit per battle SAP now I'm not
going to be guessing a money per hour
because it can vary so much however for
a couple drops that will get my input on
that but we managed to get 15 battle
staff so that's about 15k profit in the
time that I was recording this so it is
pretty profitable however you will need
a fair amount of starting cash you can
see we already burned it
120 cages for those 15 Bell slabs but
it's really easy and can be profitable
okay so next up we're checking out Rome
Edie's clothing store now this is on the
second level of the gnome stronghold
once you go up the ladder here or the
first level I should say now but once
you go up to lather it's a little bit to
the northeast and it's the gnome in the
purple attire so the big benefit of this
store is the items are extremely cheap
and you can sometimes sell them for a
massive margin like let's have a look at
these turquoise boots right now $17.99
each and they're valued at 200 coins and
if we have a look on that GE tracker
here it's reasonably accurate to sell it
for possibly 18 under like look at that
for the last week
it's been selling for 1800 of course
these are very slow sells but if you
really just don't have that much money
you can make a ton of money here so what
you just do is that's by five of these
guys look at the blue boots so 200 into
ATM for those as well well buy five of
those as well
green boots are valuable to add a 719 we
could have a quick look at those guys
yeah green boots are probably worth
doing to look like we could go there
selling upwards of 18 under as well now
these are just fashion scape items or
sometimes clans will use them so that's
kind of why they actually have a purpose
so after that you just hop worlds and
here you don't really have to worry
about hitting a logging cap too much
because you fill up your inventory
pretty quickly and then you could just
have to run to the bank which I'll show
you in a second here so we'll just buy
some more of these turquoise boots and
some more blue boots and some more green
boots these guys sometimes we'll have
good margins on them as well you just
kind of have to check all the items
because there is no rhyme or reason to
why he's either himself or what they do
it just kind of depends on who wants
them at the time once your inventory is
full you can't imagine just run down
here and there is a bank in the kind of
south western corner so this method is
for beginner people who don't have a lot
of money if you just have let's say 10
or 15 thousand coins I can easily double
or triple your money just by investing
the money into boots and waiting for
them to sell so I always see a lot of
people doing this method now it's also
in the Nome stronghold I'm literally
just a bit north of where the bank was
just ran up here and
talking to Ludo now he sells a ton of
different ingredients but what most
people buy is the pineapple because
there's only worth two coins and it
sells for about a hundred on the grand
exchange 130 right now so this would be
ideal for people who are literally 100%
broke by buying all ten of these you're
gaining about 1 Cayne profit roughly and
then you just hop world the reason that
I not really sold on this so far is that
you fill up your inventory so quickly so
only about two years 3k per inventory
then you have to run back and forth and
look other people are doing is pretty
consistently so I it might be worth it
so let's go ahead and just buy an
inventory quickly here my god this is a
popular spot apparently I will to keep
hopping around here so yeah you get
about 2.5 k per inventory so I think
this might be 200 K now or maybe
something like that if you're not
fighting with other people for it but
just because of that alone is not even
worth it you can see I already sold off
three of my blue boots already as well
for 1800 which is amazing one other
thing I meant to mention is just from
that one inventory assuming that sell
all my items for that price I'll be
making 32 K now of course you wouldn't
make an hourly rate here because it's
really gonna depend on how quickly you
can sell the items however that's still
really nice to see so yeah we pretty
much got an inventory here already so
that's about it costs us next to nothing
so that's about 3.3 K so I could see how
if you were brand new and totally poor
this might be worth it however I
wouldn't really recommend this as a
hourly method because you really aren't
gonna get that much okay so next up this
is one of my favourite shops to buy from
however it does have a requirement to
get in you need to get access to the
Warriors guild now the easiest way to
get that is to have a 65 attack in 65
strength however you can do with 99 if
any of those but is less likely now what
I like about this method is for one you
don't really need a lot of starting cash
you probably need like 20 to 30 K but
you can get upwards of about 600 to 700
our from a very entry level money making
method the obviously you're not getting
any experience or anything like that
however what you're gonna to do is buy
items from
liddie Oh now what this guy sells is
plain pizzas and potatoes with cheese's
we're gonna buy them up quickly before
someone else does we have a look at that
it's selling for about 450 for the plain
pizza and about 400 for the potato with
cheese so we just made well let's see
how much they value dad and 11 coins and
50 coins so not a whole lot and so we
made 3 or 50 off this one and about 400
or something off that one so we made
like 3k or something now this place is
extremely close to a bank which is
awesome and the items stock up to 10 so
if you're not actually fighting anyone
for it you can get a ton of items very
quickly or I believe one of them stocks
up to 10 and the other one stocks up to
5 or 6 or something like that either way
you can fill your inventory extremely
quickly however if somebody else is
doing it you will be fighting with them
and there are iron men who use this item
is a general food source so they will be
buying those out as well however if you
do it a non peak hour you can do pretty
well for yourself here okay so next up
on the list is the meat shop in canvas
now to get here you will need to do
priests in peril and it's but it though
and now this guy Rufus sells a couple
items that are worth buying
the main one is the raw shark however he
only stocks one now that sharks are only
worth 720 each it's not that great but
we'll have a look at some of the other
items he sells I mean when I thought
this worth buying is raw bear means that
740 GP profit there and abut another 300
so it's about 1k per full items that you
buy and then you can just switch worlds
and but not that many people are
actually here and it's right north of a
bank which is a pretty vital part buying
items from shops the bank needs be
fairly close buys okay so one inventory
is gonna net you 2 to 3 K once again but
really not a lot of people here raw
sharks obviously are gonna sell pretty
quickly the bear meat I might not be as
quick
yeah per day you're looking at maybe a
couple thousand so it's probably about a
full day to sell a thousand of these so
you couldn't do this for too long
whoever I think you might get three in
Turkey an hour here if you work in
suddenly doing it and you wouldn't
really have any competition which be one
of the main benefits okay next up is
probably my favorite method of buying
from shops and that is buying from the
stonemason shop this guy has some pretty
insane merchants you can take advantage
of and he sells a bunch of different
items now the requirements here is you
need to start the giant dwarf quest to
get to kilogram on top of that you will
need quite a bit of money to actually
consistently buy items from the shop but
let's have a look here so the item I buy
the most is the gold leaf if we examine
it right now it looks like it's selling
for 138 K and buying for 130 K let's
have a look on G tracker here at the
gold leaf apparently it is actually
selling for 138 so I think once I'm done
this video I might actually go buy some
gold Leafs that's an insane margin 9 K
so what you want to do is just buy one
and hop world's now it's more ideal if
you can actually buy a couple items per
world then you're not wasting as much
time but yeah the marble block on top of
that also has an insane margin on it
right now
so let's go have a look at that item -
marble block looks like it's selling for
about 345 that seems quite a bit higher
than normally is at I'm not sure what is
going on right now but yeah we'll buy
one of those why not oh my god I just
clicked on by 10 but I didn't have
enough money that is so lucky you really
have to be careful on clicking for this
stupid thing so average can be buying
one of each per world as in hopping now
we're gonna burn through our ten mill so
quick just because of how expensive the
magic stone is and we're gonna hop one
more world so this can be the most
profitable method however I wouldn't
bank on margins like this normally
there's about a 3k margin on the gold
leaf but a 3k margin on the marble block
as well as about a 10 to 15 K margin on
the magic stone or whatever it's called
so those are more of the normal margins
however right now I'm just gonna be
making some serious Bank which is nice
so I would expect a per hour I've made
about a mil here occasionally depending
on the margins
right now I'd probably be making like
one to two million much but in insane
amount now you do have to worry about
world hopping here because you do buy
that ends up very quickly so I would
probably take a one minute break every
five or six hops here
otherwise you'll be getting disconnected
okay so we literally burn through all
the money and we didn't even get a full
inventory of item so we're gonna head
back to the grand exchange and we only
have about 26 K left so let's go ahead
and sell off these items so I'm gonna
pop the marble block in for 982 k and
see if it sells it does not I didn't
really expect it to but the gold leaf
really is an excellent merchant I'm
gonna pop that in there for 137 K we're
gonna 7 ke neeche that's 49 K we get
just from these items here and the
marble block and I were selling for
again a very good margin and the last
shop I'm have a look at is the one on
lunar Isles so to actually access this
you will need to complete lunar
diplomacy which does have a whole set of
requirements to do it now it is very
profitable and the shop is actually just
inside this moving the house now
surprisingly it's actually very busy
here considering that you do need to
have complete lunar diplomacy as so you
can see what items are getting bought
out here the death runes are a very
popular one at 2:47 from the GE and 225
from the shop is what it is that now she
also sells battle staffs I think you can
buy nature runes if you want to or it's
not as recommended mostly you're gonna
want to buy death runes and battle
staffs now one thing you will need to
remember is your seal of passage from
the quest otherwise Ali Baba Yaga will
not talk to you so you have to buy these
in groups of 10 and I'd buy them down to
I guess two hundred of course it does
that differ depending on what the price
on that GE is essentially just keep
hopping world and buying up the battle
slabs and any of the runes that you want
I think the astral rooms may be worth of
by as well have a look at those astral
runes you gather down to 122 they sell
for 145 in the GE in 113 here so you
could buy a smash orange
you look that one it's for battles
that's an easy 4k there and some death
runes so it's not actually to back to
you right now and yeah so that's pretty
much the gist of it just gonna keep
hopping back and forth and I have made
upwards of 1 millon our under ideal
scenarios here but you could probably
pull off I don't know 700 a entertain
our here no problem however there is a
pretty steep requirement to actually
access his place all right guys so we're
back at the gran exchange now we didn't
manage to sell all the items off because
I just kind of ripped around to a bunch
of different stalls and hasn't even been
that long we did sell all of the gold
leaves the magic stones and a fair
amount of the marble blocks or bricks or
whatever there alright so let's just see
how much money we made just with a rough
Louis buddy check with all these items
in the air even sold a fair amount of
the boots and it's coming it about a 231
K in profit just from buying from random
shops and we barely did any of them for
more than a minute I'd say we did about
10 minutes actually buying from shops
and considering that quite a few of
those were very newbie methods I'd say
that you can make some serious Bank of
course the last two or three are the
best however I thought I would leave you
guys with some options anyway guys I
hope you did enjoy the video if you did
don't forget to toss a video a like or I
dislike if you didn't like it I guess
anyway thanks for watching guys I will
see you in the next video